[Music]
here comes he goes there and he says oh
no no no I'm not even standing in line
everyone try to take a charge or
anything I'm just getting out of your
way you can just show off if you want
nobody else why uses his hand knocks it
free and that leads to the loft Anthony
Davis for the easy deuce
[Music]
the box is just overpowers exactly the
same from the field six out of nine
[Applause]
[Applause]
throws it down
just carries it to the rim caldwell-pope
doesn't wanna back out the Davis when
you're playing a player you've got
Anthony Davis coming at you you better
be ready
he really does a great job with the low
dribble Danny Green what a play show
time Danny Green throws it up there
there's the cup there's a guy there but
Anthony Davis over the top of Bay's and
chest flushes
three by onto the pinball it's picked up
by LeBron down mr. fast-break to pass
white LeBron over Yanis here for ad what
up at you boy Adam left coach you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report